is it not the case or is it the case
that human nature is somehow drawn to
the miserable stuff especially when life
itself is not that miserable in other
words you know the miserable dinner the
speech that Trump gives about carnage in
America is you know he can give it and
it's applauded precisely because
actually for most people there isn't its
picket fences and garden gnomes yeah
well I think not not everyone was
impressed my favorite comment on the
Trump carnage inauguration speech came
from former President George W Bush man
with whom I tend not to agree to put it
mildly
and he said that was some weird [ __ ] but
speaker's your point though your your
observation about human psychology is
correct there is a well-documented
phenomenon known as the negativity bias
one version of it is the phenomenon of
loss aversion that Daniel Kahneman and
Amos Tversky documented the people dread
losses more than they savor or
anticipate gains criticism stings more
than praise elevates we have a better
memory for things that go wrong things
that can go right however it is not true
that that political rhetoric therefore
must appeal to the negative because
there have been fantastically successful
politicians who have had a note of
optimism even in dark times perhaps most
famous times well Franklin Roosevelt
will have nothing to fear but fear
itself on the on the right Ronald Reagan
during a period of double-digit
inflation and unemployment had an
optimistic message Barack Obama not so
long ago was elected twice with a
message of hope and change so it can't
be done by a skillful politician tops
things aren't miserable enough for
Donald Trump's message to be so here's
my chrismad now you make a very coherent
argument for looking on the bright side
you know you're a husk you know glass
half-full guy how come there is really
no politician of prominence in America
that is able to come up with that
message or indeed in this country
yeah yeah um but where they kind of
where the lovers of the other thing no I
think that that's a it's a good question
by the way it's the message in the book
is not let's look at the let's see the
glass as half full it's let's let's see
how full the glass is again the problem
is this is not a book about optimism
this is a book about accuracy the the
fact that global poverty is declined by
50 percent in 30 years is not looking at
the bright side it's a fact that people
don't know